[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de dimanche en politique très
heureux de vous retrouver en direct sur
france 3 bourgogne le break site
comprenait la sortie du royaume uni de
l'union européenne est toujours dans
l'impasse les négociations pour un
accord n'ont pas permis d'avancer le
gouvernement britannique peine à trouver
une majorité pour sortir de cet
imbroglio le break s'ils devaient
officiellement entrée en vigueur le 29
mars finalement un délai supplémentaire
sera nécessaire
on s'interroge ce dimanche quelles
seront les conséquences du break site
britannique pour la bourgogne
comment les anglais qui vivent dans
notre région ressent-il les événements
quelles conséquences cette rupture
historique peut-elle avoir sur les
britanniques en bourgogne et sur les
entreprises de la région qui commercent
avec la grande bretagne particulièrement
pour les vins de bourgogne bien sûr on
en débat avec nos invités greta scott
bonjour vous êtes étudiante britannique
sur le campus dijonnais de sciences po
paris merci d'être avec nous philippe
gomis bonjour vous êtes délégué régional
de la chambre de commerce et d'industrie
franco britannique vous êtes
franco-britannique vous même
pierre gernelle bonjour jour vous êtes
directeur général de la fédération des
négociants éleveurs de grande bourgogne
concernait évidemment au premier chef
par ce break si du point de vue des
échanges commerciaux merci à vous
d'avoir accepté cette invitation en ce
dimanche matin vous qui nous regarde et
vous pouvez bien sûr commenter cette
émission en direct sur les réseaux
sociaux avec le hashtag dean paul
bourgogne alors avant d'aller plus loin
dans le débat je vous propose ensemble
de regarder ces images c'est l'actualité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
plus d'un million de personnes dans les
rues de londres hier pour demander à
nouveau référendum sur la sortie du
royaume uni de l'union européenne gré
d'ascot vous regardez depuis dijon à ce
qui se passe là-bas à londres chez vous
finalement quel est votre regard sur ce
rassemblement impressionnant cette marée
humaine hier pas en fait si j'étais au
royaume uni je je je manifesterai c'est
sûr mais en fait il faut il faut se
rendre compte que enfin un million de
personnes ça change pas le résultat d'un
référendum mais quand même ça veut dire
qu'il ya pas mal des gens qui sont
contre les frais qui est vraiment
veulent encore une fois l'occasion de
s'exprimer
est-ce que vous avez un regard différent
depuis que vous résidez en france ou est
ce que c'est la même chose ou est ce que
vous avez aussi une conscience
finalement deux citoyennes européennes
quelque part depuis que vous vivez en
france
en fait quelque chose que j'ai constaté
que enfin en france au moins j'ai
l'impression que les gens se sentent
plus plusieurs européens que royaume uni
vraiment il ya il ya un manque
d'identité européenne au royaume uni et
je pense que probablement ça c'est là ça
c'est ce qui a changé dans mon opinion
parce que je pense que ça le fait ce
qu'on ne sont pas européens
ça ça change ça ça change notre façon de
penser à l'union européenne et sa chance
alors s'arrondit la décision de les
quitter l'union européenne beaucoup plus
facile pour un propos que je crois film
gomis comment comment vous regardez ça
votre épouse et britanniques vous même
vous êtes franco-britannique vous avez
une entreprise là-bas d'épouser
française oui j'ai une entreprise ici en
france je suis aussi délégué des examens
diversité comme moi donc j'ai un pied
dans des seaux les deux pays un million
de personnes la rue est une
manifestation qui s'est très bien passé
des rues doyen de calme le souligne
aussi voilà ne représente pas 14
millions de personnes
il est normal qu'ils de la frustration
maintenant j'ai envie de reprendre les
termes du premier ministre
je crois que c'est pour tout le royaume
uni enough is enough
stop il ya eu un référendum je pense
qu'il est maintenant temps peut-être de
tous employés pour essayer de faire au
mieux possible respecter le vote
mais voilà il y assez normal de la
frustration du camp des rues man 2 il y
en a actuellement aussi des camps des
practices des liseuses
mais il faut maintenant trouver un
terrain de paix aussi parce que vous
avez vu des images l'angleterre
actuellement est divisée complètement
divisé ce n'est pas le seul pays en
europe actuellement être combattants
divisée non mais on a nos sociétés aussi
vous avez vos soucis mais le royaume uni
pour moi qui suis franco britannique
le royaume uni ce qu'une grande nation
on sait être soudés lorsqu'il le faut et
je pense qu'il est maintenant temps
qu'on se ressoude ensemble pour
affronter ça mais de façon rapide parce
que les entreprises et le monde du
travail du business notamment bourgogne
franche comté ne peut plus vivre dans
cet institut
on va venir aux échanges commerciaux
dans un instant mais pierre vernel j'ai
envie de vous interroger d'abord avant
de parler business de vous interroger en
tant que citoyen français finalement et
européens sur sur ces images qu'on a vu
hier qu'ils sont très impressionnantes
même si comme l'on dit nos autres
invités ça ne remet pas en cause le
résultat des référendums mais ça dit
quelque chose de la situation qu'on ne
savait pas en cause mais ça dit la
volonté de rester en europe de ne pas
être dans le repli sur soi de vouloir
continuer à construire parce que la
construction européenne c'est un travail
de tous les jours c'est un travail sans
fin mais qui lorsque vous prenez un peu
de recul et je pense que c'est bien
aussi de prendre de temps en temps un
peu de recul
ça a apporté la paix en europe ça
apportait une certaine prospérité
je pense à l'euro grands chantiers
économiques et c'est vrai que tout sera
on en est bien conscient c'est quand
même une grande chance de vivre en
europe je pense malgré le fait qu'il y
avait aussi des problèmes de la
technocratie une certaine dérive
bureaucratique et je pense qu'on pouvait
essayer de changer tout ça de
l'intérieur parce qu'aujourd'hui
effectivement le danger c'est que on est
dans une économie mondialisée des
économies qui sont entremêlées claire et
indépendante interdépendantes et on
pourra pas revenir en arrière
c'est inéluctable alors il ya le débat
entre reminders et break sitters
vous avez compris ceux qui veulent
rester dans l'union européenne et ceux
qui veulent quitter l'union européenne
et puis il ya
les considérations à l'intérieur même de
ces négociations sur le brésil y a deux
jours
theresa may a obtenu au conseil européen
à délai supplémentaire parce que
finalement le parlement britannique est
divisée il n'y a pas de majorité pour
voter l'accord entre le royaume uni et
l'union européenne en matière de sorties
est ce que ce nouveau délai
supplémentaire vous qui connaissez bien
le pays et la mentalité britannique vous
pensez que c'est de nature à apaiser les
choses et à calmer la situation greta
scott
ben je sais pas parce que je pense que
le délai ne s'est pas assez lent pour
pour changer grand chose
déjà on avait vu que parce que le
speaker de la chambre des communes
john parker lui il a dit que tu lisais
mais elle ne peut qu a présenté son dire
encore une fois
alors et alors que le conseil européen
vient de dire qu'en fait non vous devez
présenter le dire encore une fois pour
commencer pour qu'on puisse savoir
quelle quelle devrait être la date c'est
la sortie du royaume uni a dit l'union
européenne oui parce que sinon ils iront
risque d'être obligé d'organiser des
élections en grande-bretagne pour les
élections européennes ce qui serait
presque un comble fils hugo me sens
ridicule ridicule oui mais tient un
petit peu logique parce que ça
enlèverait une partie de légitimité à la
nouvelle assemblée européenne et lui
s'il ya des citoyens qui ne sont pas
représentés c'est presque peut-être même
limite au niveau du droit européen
heureux problème c'est que des élections
européennes au royaume uni dans un état
de tension maximum comme cela quels sont
les députés qui arriveront à l'union
européenne
lequel parti de quelle sensibilité
premièrement deuxièmement vis-à-vis de
la phase de l'union européenne un pays
qui est en train de négocier une sortie
faire voter aux élections européennes
envoyer des députés là bas vigilant il
faut être logique et remettons les
choses quand même dans le contexte il ya
deux ans lorsque le premier ministre
theresa may a demandé l'activation de
l'article 50 du traité lisbonne qui
prévoit donc lula sur la soumission
le parlement a voté à la majorité
écrasante et nous sommes actuellement à
un problème où nous avons des politiques
en c'est un problème de politique
britannique
uniquement sauf que c'est un problème de
politique britannique oui oui et
on parle beaucoup du deal de theresa may
non c'est un deal que l'union européenne
a négocié le dialecte barnier qui était
négociateur pour le voile et maintenant
il ya des rumeurs depuis ce matin que
rétention de tête n'est pareil en cas de
démission si jamais deux personnes du
parti conservateur souhaite devenir
premier ministre
il va falloir organiser des élections
internes au parti conservateur pour
changer de premier ministre
et cela peut durer à peu près deux mois
rien va se résoudre
je pense qu est ce qu il faut faire
accepter le deal de l'europe il n'est
pas si mauvais pour pour la
grande-bretagne à ces affreux ça va
coûter la grande partie à une 42
milliards d'euros annoncés pas c'est pas
un bon accord et donc qu'il faut pas il
donc les finalement les députés
britanniques qui sont divisés et a
beaucoup qui ont raison bah oui on avait
lui il y en a beaucoup qui a également
on ne paraissant jamais enfin selon moi
même j'ai conservé que l'on existe
coûterait de l'argent à la grande
bretagne
oui en fait mais non mais c'est normal
mais également si même si on sort sans
accord fin il y aura il y aura une
récession c'est même pas une question
qu'on parle beaucoup de l'avant de
bretagne ce qu'il faut constater dans
cet épisode c'est la grande unité de
l'union européenne le ses 27 états
membres qui ont fait preuve d'un certain
sang-froid
malgré aussi on sait des intérêts
nationaux de part et d'autre qui
pouvaient mêlée on veut dire avoir un
impact négatif sur cette négociation et
je trouve
et ça je tire mon chapeau habitent sur
un michel barnier mais à toute son
équipe à la commission européenne qui a
su faire preuve d'une véritable
stratégie européenne pour essayer de
gérer au mieux cette négociation on va
parler du président vue dissidents un
instant mais sur térésa mais puisqu'elle
semblent sur la sellette
est-ce que je vous demandais de sortir
votre boule de cristal est ce qu'elle va
démissionner elle doit démissionner dans
l'être dans les jours qui viennent
est ce que ça changera les choses
j'espère moi ce que je sais c'est qu'il
faut que cette semaine sa décision dans
quelle direction nous va soit un no deal
sont si no deal soit on arrête le
processus de sortie d'une aubaine qui se
rêvait aussi pour moi une crise aussi
une crise antidémocratique
mais il faut que pour le monde de
l'entreprise pour les citoyens
britanniques sachent cette semaine si
une sortie sans deal qu'on ait le temps
de se préparer
donc après sur lucio sortie 110 110 avec
sortie avec deal ou report de la sortie
de l'union européenne cinédit et parce
que ou quatrième option élections
européennes et une sortie on verra dans
une salle ira bien avec le report je
pense c'est votre point de vue aussi il
faut savoir maintenant on est à un
moment où les choses doivent s'arrêter
oui oui en fait on a perdu beaucoup
beaucoup de temps c'est vrai mais fin
c'est difficile à dire vraiment vraiment
c'est difficile à dire enfin
personnellement je crois pas que tu aies
mais enfin je sais pas mais tu aimais
normalement si c'était si c'était un
autre premier ministre et devait être
démissionné joint à trois fois déjà
alors si elle va démissionner a pas eu
de majorité la question à se poser c'est
est-ce qu'un premier ministre qui était
dans le camp des oui mahina et est à
même de pouvoir porter une décision du
peuple britannique de sortir de l'union
européenne et ça c'est la question on se
rend compte que voilà on a voté pour un
break site au moment d'y passer
on a l'impression qu'ils sont tous au
bord du précipice comme c'est un peu ça
oui alors est-ce qu'on se sent aussi
chez nous au bord du précipice quand on
est citoyen britannique greta scott
comment comment vous sentez les choses
en vivant finalement encore dans l'union
européenne alors que votre pays je sais
pas s'il est au bord du précipice mais
en tous les cas il est au bord de la
sortie de l'union européenne passe t'il
histoire de stress et de de colère
franchement enfin je sais pas comment on
va sortir de l'union européenne si on va
sortir quand est-ce que ça va se passer
commande là bas il ya beaucoup beaucoup
situation il n'y a pas du tout de
stabilité je sais pas comment je peux
rester ici
oui et en fait je suis si ce tracé
qu'une fois et minuit j'ai envoyé un
texto à mon ami français pour lui
demander que l'on peut obtenir la
nationalité française
alors vous voyez déjà alors que vous
êtes là depuis combien de temps si moins
six mois voilà déjà et vous imaginez que
pour les étudiants pour les étudiants
britanniques qui viennent en europe
étudier on sait bien que les étudiants
britanniques vont aussi ailleurs étudié
ils vont pas qu'en europe mais pour ceux
qui viennent en europe étudier ça
changerait les choses vous par exemple
hors union européenne vous seriez venu a
dit
ont étudié enfin je sais pas oui
probablement parce que j'adore la france
ouais mais y avait été plus compliqué
oui c'est sûr et ça va être plus
compliqué parce que déjà enfin j'essaie
au moins à ce respect à sciences po les
frais de scolarité sont basés sur six en
est membre de l'espace économique
européen on pas alors après il met les
frais de scolarité vont augmenter jusqu
au maximum et même si ça vaut à peu près
la même le même prix que que la la
le prix de scolarité au royaume uni
lorsque je suis ici je reçois pas dead
je reçois pas d'un prêt décision du
gouvernement britannique est également
les protons que je sache les bourses
étudiantes
il s'appuie en france ne s'applique pas
enfin s applique qu aux étudiants qui
sont nombreux l'union et vous si on vous
verse quelque chose au royaume uni ça
sera en livres sterling et donc vous
serez perdante si la livre est d'évaluer
dans l'est dans les semaines qui
viennent c'est ça a déjà commencé
malheureusement logique gomis je vais
juste rajouter c'est bien la communauté
britannique aussi la plus libre était
dit que j'ai moi même une société donc
de formation en langues étrangères j'ai
à peu près douze salariés britanniques à
dijon de nationalité britannique et
c'est panique à bord c'est à dire que
nous on avait déjà anticipé on leur
avait demandé d'aller s'enregistrent
auprès des préfectures pour avoir des
cartes de séjour
on a reçu un document des douanes il y a
à peu près un mois disant attention il
faut se préparer à aubes redted ça fait
deux ans ça fait que les graines ont
pris l'avancé ou du retard l'information
ils ont prévu je pense qu'ils anticipent
à ce que au final c'est le politique qui
décide donc il anticipe par rapport à ce
que le politique décidera de répit
jeunesse à faire du stand d'information
le sénat français a voté des lois
justement sur une situation post briques
site sur les ressortissants britanniques
au mois d'octobre
toujours est il que dans ma société j'ai
donc des gens qui ont vécu plus de 5 ans
donc qu'ils peuvent avoir une carte de
séjour permanent ici en france
j'en ai d'autres qui ont qui sont
arrivés il ya six mois
question - en tant qu'employeur qu'est
ce que je fais en cas de nos deals avec
ses salariés la cas il faudra le temps
d'un accord entre la grande-bretagne
consignes mais après le no deal européen
l'accord mais la date
wydad la date du mur c'est le 12 avril
donc trois semaines je pense aussi
certains employés qui ont été retraités
en angleterre qu'ils perçoivent leur
pension en livres sterling voilà qu'ils
se fassent l autre cas c'est la question
du pouvoir d'achat
exactement on a des familles qui sont
dans des situations
on va dire d'angoise terrible moi j'ai
envie de poser la question à philippe à
ce que les breaks sitters lorsqu'ils ont
décidé
ils ont passé ce qu'ils ont pensé à tout
ça et c'est là où encore une fois par
rapport à ce référendum on peut se poser
des questions parce que bien entendu on
pose une simple question de répondre par
oui ou par non mais c'est maintenant
finalement on se rend compte des
conséquences de tout ça nous conduisait
donc effectivement ça pose vraiment
question alors ses conséquences
peut-être qu'elle est elle intègre des
briques sitter peut-être je ne sais pas
toujours est il que j'ai l'impression
qu'on agit actuellement ce soit en
france ou dans l'union européenne ou au
royaume uni dans une précipitation folle
parce que on parle on prend son temps on
parlait plus la date approche plus on va
dans une action d'urgence etc
c'est pas bon c'est pas bon et je
prendrai juste interne
vous savez dans nombre d affaires ont
dit que le plus grand muscles du monde
des affaires c'est le calme alors le
calme oui il faut rester calme lundi
mais là c'est quand même la tempête fait
de répondre c'est que l'union européenne
a proposé un accord en fin d'année et
que depuis ses côtés d'antoine côté
parlement britannique qui a les
tergiversations oui tous en sachant le
calme il est à bout sachant qu'à
l'origine normalement l'accord devait
être signé entre le gouvernement
britannique et l'union européenne est
terminée et avec une application ce sont
les parlementaires britanniques avaient
saisi la justice britannique pour dire
nous on veut avoir mais revenons à dire
pour le deal conséquences aussi d'un
point de vue touristique est ce que vous
avez l'impression puisqu'on parle
notamment du cours de la livre sterling
que ça va jouer que ça joue déjà cette
incertitude sur le tourisme des
britanniques qui viendrait dans notre
région regrette ascot
oui parce qu'en fait une fois mon père
m'a dit je sais il ya quelques mois il
m'a dit ah oui en fait maintenant y aura
jean frey qu'il faut payer pour venir en
europe son assiette alors même s'il sait
rien mais enfin je rigolais je me sais
c'est fou c'est laid c'est pas vrai
vraiment vraiment je pensais que c'était
une blague
et enfin clairement s'il faut payer
joint ce que ce genre de choses alors il
y aura le y aura le coup et puis il y
aura aussi
la paperasse ça c'est inévitable fils
gomis vous avez déjà ce genre de
situation qui se prépare alors l'accord
russo d'accord l'accord pour le mans
bilatérale qui entre le royaume uni et
l'union européenne
c'est n'y aura pas besoin de visa il n'y
aura pas besoin de ce coup ci le
parlement brialy gratifie exactement
exactement
ensuite en cas de mode il je pense que
il va y avoir quand même un échange on
peut pas appliquer des visas comme cela
je pense que mon serait sur un ce qu'on
appelle un noël place ce qui se passe en
norvège par exemple pouvoir échanger etc
c'est dès l'instant où vous souhaitez
aller travailler ou étudier au royaume
uni qu'il faudra un visa maintenant au
niveau des échanges touristiques
ça va être le pouvoir d'achat ça va être
le pouvoir d'achat est là il ya un vrai
risque en bourgogne franche comté par
exemple de voir des citoyens
britanniques choisir d'autres destinées
à laurie ya un vrai risque sur les
touristes il ya un vrai risque si pour
des entreprises qui achètent des
matières premières en angleterre qui
pour le moment d'un mois à l'autre ne
sait pas vraiment quel coût ils vont
payer si jamais ils n'ont pas des ce
qu'on appelle des plafonds de
sécurisation au niveau de la livre
sterling
voilà il faut que ce climat et ça je
leur dis et je ne sais pas si le
gouvernement britannique montant drame
et j'ai envoyé un email pour tout vous
dire de colère un peu vendredi matin il
faut qu'on sache ou non du travail il
faut qu'on sache on peut plus permettre
de cesse que vous avez vous dans vos
collaborateurs vous même je pose la
question s'ils arrêtent ascot des gens
qui se disent bas on va rentrer au
royaume uni on restera pas en france on
en a oui oui oui oui on en a eu qui se
sont posé la question et j'ai des amis
qui sont rentrés au royaume uni et le
pire je vais le dire ici il ya deux ans
je recrutais jeu c'était en phase de
recrutement et je reçois une française
qui avait vécu pendant 20 ans qui était
professeur de français dans un collège
en angleterre et la dû retourner en
france où la pression des parents qui
ont dit voilà
veuille vous rentriez donc mais on est
sur une situation très tendue on parlait
des entreprises des échanges commerciaux
on va y venir pierre gernelle 15
millions de bouteilles de vins de
bourgogne vendus en grande-bretagne en
2017 un chiffre d'affaires de plus de
145 millions d'euros
autant dire que pour vous c'est énorme
et c'est très très risqué ce qui est en
train de se passer très risqué non je
dirais pas ça je dirais que les
relations entre nos amis anglais la
bourgogne elles sont ancestrales et qu
on a vécu d'autres des sciences
historiques majeurs et on a continué à
marchander à vendre des vins de
bourgogne en grande bretagne et les amis
anglais continueront de boire des vins
de bourgogne dans les mois et les années
qui viennent
mais ce sera compliqué la tâche sera
compliquée la tâche
ça va compliquer la tâche d'un point de
vue technique logistique et c'est déjà
le cas puisqu'il ya déjà des
anticipations alors j'ai envie de dire
que les anticipations
elles font que le business pour le
moment et pour l'instant c'est à dire
que en fait du côté de la grande
bretagne ont fait des stocks de vins de
bourgogne c'est ça on fait descendre
prévisions un peu comme en temps de
guerre ce qui est assez incroyable en
temps de guerre c'est pas forcément le
vin qu'on constate mais je veux dire on
fait des stocks à mon frère on anticipe
c'est pas de la peur s'est on anticipe
comme le dit philippe nous on est des
chefs d'entreprises donc nous on est là
pour anticiper on sait que on finira par
trouver un accord la grande bretagne et
notamment les cosses doivent exporter du
scotch en noir et blanc est donc
clairement on a besoin d'un accord
commercial dans les deux sens et puis
les britanniques adore les vins de
bourgogne
voilà les britanniques adore les vins de
bourgogne ceci dit on sait que si un new
deal et si un vrai break site je pense
que la grande bretagne pourrait vouloir
relancer les relations avec les anciens
pays du cra du commonwealth et forcément
il ya des puits ce qu'on appelle nous
dans le jargon du vin les pays du
nouveau monde l'australie la nouvelle
zélande qui sont déjà très présents en
grande bretagne et qui font des vins
qu'ils nous concurrencent je pense
notamment au pinot noir de nouvelle
zélande est là clairement on sait que
notamment sur les entrées de gamme il y
aura une concurrence accrue parce qu'il
y aura peut-être des droits de douane
différentiel qui feront qu'on pourrait
est ce que vous l'avez d'ajustement est
ce que vous craignez des droits des
droits de douane
donc finalement un coût plus important
pour livrer exporter votre vin en grande
rade oui c'est un coup un coup et puis
la réglementation on va dire il
accomplit sa team
sachant que la grande bretagne c'est le
deuxième pays ces 15 % des exportations
donc c'est c'est un pays majeur ce qu'il
faut aussi savoir c'est qu'il ya les
vins qui sont consommés en grande
bretagne mais il y avait aussi une
activité de 20 et hongrois sont
réexportés de grande bretagne vers
d'autres pays
et ça je pense que cette activité risque
disparaître assez rapidement on a vu du
chablis un peu pour pour pour les
vignobles du chablisien c'est là
carrément le premier pays où alors
exportations à chablis et un peu moins
mâcon sont très exposées en grande
bretagne donc effectivement l'impact
pourrait être un petit peu plus
important mais encore une fois la
stratégie d'exportation des vins de
bourgogne
c'est la diversification diversification
vers tous les pays majeurs consommateurs
de vin je pense aux états unis je pense
à l'asie je pense aussi aux autres pays
de l'union européenne donc on va dire
que le travail forcé casio risque il est
encore mesurée
on est vigilant mais on n'a pas peur
vous n'avez pas peur film gomis est ce
que vous sentez cette que cette
incertitude peut faire du tort aux vans
bourgogne il ya cette incertitude c'est
le premier point il y aura effectivement
ce qu'on disait les complique la
complexification administratives et puis
la troisième chose c'est encore le cours
de la livre sterling parce que le vin
français pourrait coûter plus cher aux
anglais
alors oui maintenant si on prend un
secteur qui consomment les vins de
bourgogne en angleterre je pense que
vous avez les chiffres c'est comme une
frange de la population britannique
je pense que cette frange continuera à
acheter quoi qui lie même si la
bouteille plus cher oui sur ces produits
bien spécifiques et notamment du tiroir
de la bourgogne
il y aura il n'y aura pas forcément une
baisse drastique de la consommation peut
être y aura moins de consommation mais
les britanniques continueront à acheter
voilà
mais j'en profite aussi pour répondre à
pierre sur une interrogation qui portait
tout à l'heure sur l'union européenne et
sur le monde des affaires
j'ai l'impression aussi dans les médias
bref si tu veux dire contient européen
dire que les britanniques ont à cette
image maintenant d'anti-européen on veut
absolument sortir de l'union européenne
et on n'a plus besoin de commercer avec
la maison européenne vous avez toujours
donné l'impression d'être un peu des
européens à part en vacances des
insulaires exactement et donc ce
référendum ait lieu
non le royaume uni et sa set ça doit
être très clair
on est profondément attaché à l'union
européenne
au niveau des échanges commerciaux
niveau de ce qui a été le fondement de
l'union européenne j'ai le business qua
non non il ya légal business mais après
il ya tout ce qui va être autour de la
culture des échanges également avec les
universités etc
pendant que les prêts mathis mme
pragmatisme britten suprématiste
britannique flight encore plus que ça
parce qu'il ya vraiment des échanges et
je pense que le gouvernement et la roux
dit c'est pas parce qu'on va sortir de
l'union européenne qu'il n'y aura plus
des changes nous reste peu de temps dans
cette émission claire gernelle vous
qu'est ce que vous attendez de la
semaine qui arrive on parle de la
démission de teresa mais on doit cadre
de la clarification la clarification
il faut maintenant aller dans un sens ou
dans un autre mais il faut y aller on
peut pas rester comme ça ça fait
maintenant trop longtemps est clairement
bien sûr que moi je souhaite y des
allemands que la grande bretagne reste
dans l'union européenne mais je suis
aussi respectueux d'un vote démocratique
et donc de la clarification tous parce
que vous avez l'impression que très
rapidement ça va se ressentir dans vos
échanges là ça va ça c'est quelque part
on a déjà encore une fois anticipé et de
toute façon passera par une période qui
va être un petit peu plus compliqué on
sait qu'au niveau douaniers au niveau
logistique et va y avoir quand même des
répercussions mais encore une fois si on
raisonne on va dire à moyen ou long
terme
je pense qu'on continuera à avoir des
liens forts avec la grande bretagne
c'est ce qu'on souhaite fils gomis de
l'émir la même chose je l'avais un peu
dit tout à l'heure il faut savoir -
voilà moi je réponds enough is enough
on a besoin de clarté il faut que cette
semaine elle a pu être très à la mode et
intérêts à mais la semaine prochaine
peut-être attendait peut-être peut-être
que deux
nouveau premier ministre mais attention
attention si elle démissionne et s'il ya
plusieurs candidats qui veulent sa place
elle sera encore au pouvoir pendant un
deux mois oui donc voilà mais stop
maintenant il faut qu'on ait une
clarification
il faut qu'on soit au il faut qu'on
sache où aller pour les entreprises pour
greta haye pour les salariés pour les
étudiants pour tout le monde
voilà votre vision sur ce qui va se
passer dans les jours qui viennent
je veux qu'on prenne la bonne décision
si tout est en fait le parlement est
souverain et j'ai confiance en nos
députés
si tu veux que je peux dire oui mais la
bonne décision du coup pour moi ça va
être soit aurait un bloc l'article 50
soit on adjoint des élections à
législatives soit peut-être un nouveau
référendum les élections législatives
peut être couplé avec des élections
européennes à ce moment là parce que les
délais seront dépassés et l'union
européenne aura besoin de députés
britanniques au parlement européen même
si c'est pour quelques mois
en tout cas un délai plus long délai on
a on en a besoin c'est sûr merci merci à
tous les trois à avoir participé à cette
émission merci évidemment à vous de nous
avoir suivi on suivra de près évidemment
la suite des discussions au royaume uni
dans les prochaines heures et les
prochains jours dans un instant un point
sur l'actualité régionale celui de la
partie nationale de dimanche en
politique francis letellier reçoit
renaud muselier est président de la
région sud provence alpes côte d'azur et
député européen les républicains on
parlera de rock bien sûr bon dimanche à
tous sur france 3
[Musique]